[Music]
welcome to Ramsey Solutions break the
cycle live stream I'm Dave Ramsey I've
been teaching this personal finance
money stuff for over 30 years showing
people how to get out of debt so that
they can build wealth change their
family tree and be outrageously generous
generous in the
process we take calls on our show the
ramsy show which is a podcast a YouTube
show and a radio show now a billion
downloads on the podcast number one on
Apple last month with the second largest
Talk Radio Show in America just to give
you an idea of the scope and millions
and millions and millions of you on
YouTube thank you in the process of
doing that we talk to you also Ramsey
Solutions has a whole research arm and
we talk to you we know what's on your
mind it's kind of scary out there right
now when we talk to folks we find out
that most of you are uncertain some of
you are apathetic some of you have given
up some of you are working your tail off
and you can't seem to get ahead you've
got the rat in the wheel syndrome going
some people are just plain panicked so
what does 2024 really hold we got a
crazy economy we got inflation all over
the place we've got elections that talk
about nuts and man on top of that we got
a high interest rate environment well
tonight we're going to address headon
this uncertainty and the hopelessness
that goes with it for a lot of
folks in the last quarter all of last
fall we started doing webinars on money
and helping people with their budgets
the process of doing that we surveyed a
bunch of you we ask you three questions
what best describes your money situation
80% of those surveyed said they were in
the messy middle or in
crisis the messy middle is starts and
stops falls off the wagon can't seem to
get traction just a sense of chaos
crisis is we're on the edge of the cliff
or the car is going over the cliff I
mean we're in FA ceing foreclosure or
repossession or might any moment the
second question we asked everybody was
what are the emotions you feel when it
comes to
money three emotions popped up most
often fear folks are afraid shame and
guilt this sense that I've done
something wrong guilt that I don't have
my act together it seems like everyone
else is Ken and Barbie everyone else has
their act together but not at our house
fear shame and guilt the last question
we ask was how long have you been living
in this messy middle this crisis with
fear shame and guilt this is the saddest
answer of all most people answering that
question tens of thousands of people we
talk to say most of my adult life that
means folks are stuck and that's why
we're having this conversation tonight
don't get stuck in a cycle break the
cycle it turns out St stupid has a
gravitational pull you can get locked
into the orbit around stupid and how do
you bust an orbit well you got to expend
energy to pull away from the
gravitational pull that you've never
expended before and that's what we're
going to help you do tonight now some
folks try to do that with stuff like New
Year's resolutions well it's January
11th and most of you already blown those
that's a joke and instead what we found
is you have to make a decision to change
not a one time decision a permanent
Behavior
shift back during the uh fouchy pandemic
like everybody else I was facing a lot
of stress and we were trying to run our
business and going crazy and I ate every
dut in a 50- mile radius everything I
could eat and I got just plain
fat and I looked in the mirror I thought
this is ridiculous I've got to stop
stress eating or I'm going to the whole
thing's going to I'm just going to
explode like a Willy Wonka character or
something right so I've got to stop this
and so okay okay we're going to start
watching our intake we're going to
change our physical activity so I
started doing that and I put it on an
app and my little app says that
days consecutively I have walked or ran
one to five miles every single day
except for three days in September of
2020 when I had some kind of mystery
disease and I was in the bed I don't
know what it was so but other than that
every morning rain or shine I'm out
there because if you don't change your
behaviors you're going to keep getting
what you've been getting you got to have
a new habit walking running I got to I
got to change something I got to change
what I'm putting into my face all the
time I still got a ways to go I'm not
like in runner shape or something but
I'm 37 pounds down because of that 1371
days of a permanent Behavior change
because I am now a person that walks
every morning 30 years of helping people
get out of debt and build wealth
personal finance is very similar it's 80
% behavior and 20% head knowledge it
turns out that the mathematics of wealth
building is about the sixth grade level
you can do it but we got to change our
behaviors and we got to change our
beliefs to change our behaviors so my
question is what's keeping you stuck
what's kept you in survival mode for so
long for so many years I mean possibly
even decades my whole adult life is how
people answer the question Cycles repeat
and reinforce and the only way to break
a cycle is to start a new cycle to start
a new Behavior to replace the old
Behavior now over the next hour you're
going to hear from Ramsey personalities
who will teach from all kinds of
different angles tonight you're also
going to see a Hands-On demonstration of
the world's best budgeting app ours
every dollar we're going to walk you
through how to put that together and
we're going to give away $10,000 cash 10
winners of $1,000 to get you started to
get you moving in the right direction so
hang with us through the whole time to
see if you're one of the winners first
we want to hear from Dr John deloney
Ramsey personality mental health expert
two phds the Dr John deloney show on
podcast is an absolute blowout it's a
huge success his last two books have
been number one hits including his L
latest one last fall building a
non-anxious life stress Cycles devastate
every area of Our Lives not just our
bank accounts all right John take it
away
hey thanks Dave Hey listen good folks
you made it you made it 2024 every New
Year's for my friends that are watching
this yall know I overdo it I'm so
optimistic about New Year's my friends
make fun of me and this year feels
different I was talking to my wife
recently I'm not feeling the optimism
this year and everybody I talk to all
over the country they're feeling it too
everything's everybody's got a pit in
their stomach things don't feel right we
can talk about it all like Dave was
talking about from politics to the wars
going on overseas from the fact that
Taylor Swift finally put some non-name
football player named Travis on the map
right but tonight we're going to talk
about money between inflation the
housing market cost of living student
loans all it it's just expensive to
breathe in 2024 and the money stress is
real you can't sleep and you're snapping
at your kids you're just distant from
from somebody that you love right
everybody's anxious everybody wants to
stop the panic attacks everybody just
wants to go to
sleep everybody thinks they're
broken you think you're broken and I
want to propose something you may have
never considered before I think your
body I think your body's working
perfectly the discomfort and the anxiety
you feel is your body's way of getting
your attention and letting you know
you're not safe if your credit cards are
maxed and you have no savings if you did
some napkin math and you're going to be
paying off your student loans for the
next 41 years or if you can't afford to
pay for a flat tire your body would be
failing you if it let you rest and relax
if it let you sleep if it let you goof
off with your friends or have a deep
connected intimate moment with a
romantic partner your body's just doing
its job the problem is we've created a
life and a financial reality that our
bodies were never designed to live in
and this isn't just sciency nerds stuff
I know about money anxiety because I've
lived it and on the Ramsey Show I talk
about mental health and marriage and
relationships I get it I usually don't
talk about my personal finance
challenges this is a vulnerable
vulnerable side of me if you will but I
want to give you a picture of what this
looks like on the other side my wife and
I didn't come from much my dad was a
minister and a police officer my wife's
parents were teachers and they all
worked really really hard when we got
married I wanted us to have no money
stress I wanted me and my wife to have
no money stress I want you to hear me
say that and I tried to solve it by
earning a lot and borrowing a lot we
took out massive student loans to get
degrees that would land us fancy jobs
with fancy titles we bought a house that
we couldn't afford we had cars that we
couldn't afford and I remember my wife
being asleep and I remember my kid being
asleep and I remember being wide awake
and I couldn't exhale
and I remember the shame because I had
all the answer I had all these graduate
degrees I was responsible for millions
of dollars in my
job and I couldn't keep my household
budget together and I remember the guilt
I kept buying things all the time
spending money I didn't have robbing
Peter to pay pa my marriage suffered my
parenting suffered my work
suffered and hear me out my story is
your story
we're in this together I'm you and
you're me I know how it feels and it
doesn't have to be like this yes
sometimes I still get scared I still
feel guilty sometimes shame still hovers
around but I'm not anxious anymore I
don't have panic attacks anymore I'm not
at war with my body anymore now I often
fall asleep way before my wife does I
want you to know the non-anxious life
this peace inside out of all this chaos
it's possible for you too I promise if
you want to break this cycle of anxiety
and money in your life I want to offer
you two important benchmarks two
important ideas number one you must
choose reality you've got to face your
particular situation wherever you happen
to be you've been told your whole life
if you follow the one normal path
everything's going to be all right and
you did it you took out the loans you
got the job you got the degree you moved
to the city to follow your passion and
now you're here and it's not working the
math in your fantasy is not adding up
and yes can we just call this what it is
it was easier for your parents and
grandparents to buy a house that was
their reality the Market's different now
and yes it used to be easier for
families to live on a single income yes
it used to be easier to go down the
street and get a job at the local Mill
without a
degree or or yes you want to be a
fiction editor and live in downtown
Manhattan and yes you want to own an
organic farm outside of Orange County or
you just want to get a general admission
ticket to see Taylor Swift like my
friend George camell is dying to do it
all feels so
impossible the world got really
expensive for the time being it's not
going to change and becoming angry and
resentful and railing against the system
is like being super mad that it's hot in
Arizona it's not going to change the
weather it's just chafing against
reality the question isn't what clever
post you can put up on Twitter or how
angry can you possibly be or who's just
the right person to vote for the
question is what are you going to do
now what are you going to do now
choosing realities about owning how life
and the world truly is not stomping
around and complaining about how you
wish it would be own it
this is how much you owe this is what it
actually costs to live in this city this
is what our life actually is this is
what it will cost to safely buy a home
this is how much this job actually pays
period this is our country of course you
want new cars and kids in the right
schools and vacations and just a home I
get it and there's a snake on every
corner that's going to loan you the
money to get those things right now even
though you can't afford them choosing
reality is not about getting the best
interest rate or about your credit score
choosing reality is about being honest
about who owns you all right second
thought if you want to break the money
anxiety cycle you must choose freedom
and when I say choose Freedom I'm not
talking about putting on an American
flag underwear and running around your
neighborhood I'm talking about choosing
freedom is not owing anyone anything
ever and yes I'm talking about living
debt-free and I know you're like oh did
Dave Ramsey pay you to say that because
actually yes he's paying me to right now
to say that but listen I'm telling you
that the data confirms what Dave has
taught for over 30 years if your body
knows that you owe money if your body
knows your nervous system knows that
you're not deciding what you do tomorrow
the bank is
your abusive boss is the mortgage
company is if your body knows you owe
money it will sound the anxiety alarms
and as I said earlier my wife and I we
didn't come from a lot we got married I
thought freedom was new cars a big house
a whole bunch of graduate degrees I
couldn't afford those things growing up
and by God I was going to have them and
we found ourselves locked up in some
really fancy looking chains we decided
to choose Freedom we sold our house we
moved into a dorm apart apartment in a
University campus with 175 college kids
that were amazing but the smells were
something to behold but we were
Relentless and now years later we're
free and I remember that last payment
and I could finally
exhale my body let me breathe my body
let me sleep let me connect with people
in a deeper way and only then could I
really truly start working on being a
better husband and a better dad and
actually start asking what kind of job
do I want to do what kind of Life do I
want to craft for me and my family what
kind of job do I not have to do anymore
you don't get out of debt just to get
out of debt you get out of debt to have
an
extraordinary generous
life this is
freedom since joining Ramsay I've had
best-selling books I hit show I'm on the
Ramsay show my finances look very
different right now than they did
Growing Up they do recently I decided to
get a new car and as a former Texan
who's always compensating for something
I was planning to get a massive giant
truck with cash and I waled up to the
dealership and I was like listen here
show me your biggest trucks and when it
was all said and
done I bought a hybrid
Highlander a Highlander the least tough
guy car in the world it's good for and
groceries and soccer
balls and the spare running shoe or I
wanted a tundra so bad and I had the
cash for it but it wasn't right for me
and my family right now so I got an
amazing reliable car and it's not going
to impress any of my Hunting Buddies but
my wife likes me my kids like me so I
don't care this is freedom now listen
that may not be what Freedom looks like
for you when it comes to cars Jade
Warsaw she has an amazing uh Cadillac
Rachel Cruz has an awesome Tesla George
campel also has a Tesla right and for
Rachel and George Tesla's battery
powered cars that's what Freedom looks
like except for hey real quick check
this out see this see this see that you
know who that is that's me that's me
pushing George camel's Tesla down the
highway because he forgot to put doublea
batteries or whatever you have to put in
those things to make them run or
whatever but maybe freedom for you is
having a car that your buddy will push
down the highway for you me and George
are just going to a punk rock show is
there anything less punk rock than two
dudes in a Tesla that won't run I don't
listen freedom is what you and your
family decide it is but it's not about
buying stuff it's about creating a
relationship with money and with
purchases that
prioritizes peace you can drive a
Corolla and have an extraordinary life
and I know this because I've done it
imagine this with me what would it feel
like to not owe anyone anything air
conditioner goes out GH that's annoying
it's not catastrophic the price of meat
and eggs skyrockets again it's not
something to weep about it's just
something to complain about your abusive
boss crosses that line and you just
smile Bye Felicia I'm out I'm I'm
leaving this is freedom this is peace
and listen you you are worth this
Freedom you're worth being well and this
life is not a pipe dream it's possible
for you and it took me and my wife years
but it's possible to choose reality to
choose freedom to do the hard work and
it will be
hard but you're worth it it won be
cheering you on every step of the way
and to keep us rolling I'm gonna welcome
back a man who only drives gas powerered
vehicles Dave
Ramsey no batteries for me John that's
right hey you can see why John's show is
so popular and why things are going so
well for him this latest book building a
non-anxious life another number one best
seller up next is George camel George's
new book is Breaking Free from broke it
releases next week on January 16th you
can still get it with pre-order goodies
on our website right now George has got
the George camel YouTube show which is
the fastest growing YouTube show in the
history of Ramsey networks it's just
going meteoric it's crazy how many of
you are watching it thank you uh he is
the king of snark we had to put a
special font in this book The snark font
if you've never heard of it you'll have
to embrace it it's pretty fun so this
guy is an incredible Communicator going
to help you with some of the villains
out there take it away George thanks
Dave I feel like I have to clear the air
after deloney just threw me under the
electric bus so here's what actually
happened what he didn't share was that
the reason my car died was because I had
to pick him up from his house which
apparently is in Narnia because he
somehow didn't have a single key for any
of their family 17 cars I mean this guy
lives so far off the grid anxiety can't
even find him on Google Maps I'm not
even sure he technically lives in
America okay and speaking of America
y'all Dave showed you some really sad
stats America has become land of the
free and home of the broke that's the
tweet for real Elon if you're watching I
refuse to call it an X or X's or
whatever you want to call I'm not doing
it I don't care how much money you spent
y'all it is so wild to me that we live
in the most advanced Society with so
much opportunity and yet we have more
stress and less money than ever before
make it make sense and if you've talked
to people lately or God forbid been in a
comment section here's the new mantra
for the American people the little man
can't get ahead that's the vibe I get
looking at the comments and as a man of
below average stature I take moderate
offense to it but I get it right maybe
you relate to that you're not where you
want to be financially and it feels like
another difficult year where you're not
going to get ahead with money you're not
going to make progress and the data
confirms this Ramy research uncovered
some sobering stats in our recent state
of personal finance report get this one
in four people said they rely on credit
cards to make ends meet they got nothing
in the bank and they're hoping Capital
one's going to save the day 50% of
people said they struggled to pay their
rent 3 % said I struggle to pay my
mortgage scary and get this one nearly
four in 10 people have Z in savings
y'all one emergency away from their life
imploding and here's what that leads to
half of Americans said they worry about
personal finances daily every day they
wake up that same lump in the throat
that pit in the stomach they get in
their car they go to the job they hate
just hoping to cover the bills this is
no way to live that's Bleak stuff and
maybe some of those stats hit close to
home for you now there's a whole bunch
of reasons for this that we could get
into and in fact let's do it because I
think it's kind of fun to point some
fingers I mean we could blame inflation
which has had its largest increase in 40
years we could blame the housing market
with home values Rising almost 50% over
the past decade we could blame the cost
of higher education College tuition's
out of control it's increased by almost
400% since the 1980s and of course we
could blame the FED for raising interest
rates making debt more expensive and
more crippling than ever and we can't
leave out the president whatever old
white man or middle-aged woman is
elected in 2024 and for whatever reason
you think they're going to ruin
everything you could blame Congress who
can't balance a budget to save their
lives and finally we can't leave out the
Elder Generations like the Baby Boomers
who yell at us youngsters to get off
their lawns from the comfort of a home
they paid $30,000 and a bushel of
raspberries for back in
1973 Gary's going to Gary it's just how
he is
and Boomers while we're on it we love
you but please turn the flashlight off
on your smartphone yes it is on right
now and I I know you didn't mean to all
right that was a lot and all of that
honestly was a little cathartic I
understand while why people complain now
it feels really good but where do you
fit into all this mess cuz so far it
sounds like it's everyone else's problem
to fix so how do we get here and what do
we do well I've got a theory for how we
got here it all started when you were a
wee little lad or lass you were never
taught financial literacy in school so
you had no clue how money worked but hey
at least you remember what year the war
of 1812 happened right and to make
matters worse you probably grew up in a
home where money wasn't talked about or
when it was talked about it was
stressful and there was money fights and
what did our parents tell us college is
a necessary path to Upward Mobility so
it's okay to take out student loans it's
an investment it's good debt so you
financed your way through college with
Sally May's Monopoly money and you had
no clue how big the payments would would
be after graduation or how the interest
worked and then while on campus what
happens the sales rep lures you into
your first credit card in exchange for a
T-shirt and a freaking Pizza CU you got
to build your credit score somehow right
this is the gateway drug to a worse life
and of course you tell yourself I'll pay
the card off every month and I'll get
the rewards I'll be winning I'll beat
the system and then life happens and you
couldn't pay it off in full and it
triggered insane interest rates and
after graduation you didn't start out
making this amazing 6ig your dream job
that you hoped you would and as a young
professional you're like well it's time
to upgrade the car so what do you do
before you know it you're tied to a car
payment that lasted longer than your
first job and much longer longer than
your last relationship and I know she
said it wasn't you but it was you Brad
it was you so you were told renting is a
massive waste of money after that right
your parents are like you got to buy a
house you got to buy a house and you
watched too much Joanna gains and you
too much Zillo and the bank is going to
loan you way more than should be legal
and so what happens you're chained to 30
years of payments on a house that you're
going to be sick of in about five and
all of these decisions leave you
financially tapped trapped strapped
capped and Zapped y' this is the most
depressing Dr Seuss book of all time you
were promised the American dream and you
were delivered the American Nightmare
and that should make you angry they told
you it would be the land of milk and
honey if you just follow this path this
is the way everyone needs to go and
instead of milk and honey you got soy
milk and Splenda
it's disgusting I know the Splenda
they're they're very aggressive fan base
out there uh but you know the
Millennials we've moved on to AG G and
you have to say it like that to be as
pretentious and annoying as possible so
at this point y'all we got two choices
here we can throw our hands up in the
air like we just don't care because
you've given up we're going to rely on
the government to fix our problems or or
you can decide to Buck the system to
rise above it because you know now the
system is designed to screw you over and
keep you reliant on debt and stress I
mean that think about this the entire
Financial system the credit score credit
cards student loans auto loans they're
designed to keep you paycheck to
paycheck and really just steal your
income debt as a thief y'all and in my
new book Breaking Free from broke I
unpack all of these industries with lots
of humor and lots of research to expose
the system for what it really is and
show you a better way a way to live with
more peace and less stress and more
money but here's the deal you have to
believe this it's not all your fault but
it's your
responsibility it's not all your fault
but it's your responsibility and the
good news is the one factor you control
in this whole mess is you and I believe
in that guy I believe in that girl and
specifically the way you handle your
money and in just a few minutes my
friends Rachel Cruz and Jade warshaw
they're going to be out here showing you
exactly how to do that very tactically
and my friend John just talked about the
importance of choosing reality and it
reminds me of the iconic scene in the
1999 Sci-Fi Action movie The Matrix Now
spoiler ahead but honestly if you
haven't seen The Matrix by now where
you're really ever going to watch it
it's been 25 years man so Morpheus in
the movie is rocking his signature
Shades his trench coat he's just blown
everyone's Minds by revealing that what
we thought was real life is actually a
simulation cooked up by some power
hungry robots so Morpheus offers Neo the
hero a choice between the red pill in
the blue pill the red pill reveals the
truth about the Matrix keeping Neo
trapped and the blue pill lets Neo
continue his life in this not so
Blissful ignorance and Neo being the
hero that he is he chooses the red pill
and he's awakened to the real world and
y' you have a similar Choice when it
comes to money for your future the
brutal truth is you were lied to and I'm
sorry it sucks I hate that you're
frustrated you're anxious and you're
feeling out of control and it reminds me
of this quote from Joe Claus the truth
will set you free but first it will piss
you off social media feeds slick Market
well-meaning family members misguided
guidance counselors and of course the
guy in the mirror hi it's me I'm the
problem it's me they've all lied to you
and worse they've stolen your paycheck
and they've stolen your joy they've
stolen your margin and it's enough we've
had enough if you're riled up and you're
ready to fight back good I'm happy for
you because that means you're sick and
tired of being sick and tired you work
too hard to feel this broke you've had
your I've had it moment and you're
drawing a line on the sand you're going
to start doing something about it
instead of just complaining about it
that's what happened to me a little over
10 years ago I just opted out I chose
the red pill I was sick of being screwed
over and I followed a different plan
called the ramsy baby steps I went
through Financial Peace University I got
on an every dollar budget and in less
than 10 years I went from flat broke
$40,000 in debt to net worth millionaire
that boggles my mind and now for the
past decade I've been bucking the system
doing money differently no credit score
no credit card no debt just living a
life of Peace and Freedom this isn't
wishful thinking or Pie in the Sky
optimism I didn't make a million dollars
in Dogecoin or from Dave coin I didn't
get a big inheritance from a long lost
Rich uncle or have a secret trust fund I
decided to carve a new path with a new
mindset and new habits and that's really
unsexy and boring I want to talk about
money so we can stop talking about money
because get this when money is no longer
an obstacle we can focus on what really
matters and become the people we really
want to be and money then becomes a tool
to help you live a life that you're
proud of instead of exhausted by and it
gives you more margin more options more
joy and more wealth than ever before and
you guys can start that journey tonight
and I wouldn't be here on this journey
if it weren't for one man and that man
is Dave Ramsey and he's going to keep
this party going here's Dave Wow way to
go George you guys can see why George
and his YouTube program and his
appearances on stage and on the Ramsey
show is so popular and why this book is
going to be a number one very very proud
of you George so the next step after
Breaking Free from the system is to
create a new reality with our new habits
and our next speaker is going to talk to
you about new habits and also talk about
Community which is absolutely important
she's a multiple number one bestselling
author including a New York Times
bestselling author and her most recent
book a children's book also hit number
one I'm glad for what I have my own
daughter Rachel Cruz take it away Rachel
so some of you guys are here tonight and
you're doing great right maybe you've
been following ramsy for a while and
you're like yeah I'm going to sign up
and just be encouraged uh but there's a
good chance that there's a lot of you
guys that are here because you want help
you look at your money situation today
and you think gosh I'm just not happy
with the result I don't like where I am
financially so when you get to that
point in your life you have to realize
okay if I'm not happy with where I am
today then I have to change what I've
been doing the habits that have gotten
me where I am have to change
and I hate to be the bearer of bad news
but you know this guys change is hard
change is uncomfortable when you look at
something different in life and you look
at it in a new way it's kind of weird
because you think oh my gosh is that
really how that works or if you actually
go through an action differently than
how you have in the past it feels weird
because it's new so if you've been
following me uh for any amount of time
you know that uh when it comes to
working outs I've not been the most
consistent I kind have a LoveHate
relationship with it and I actually kind
of uh famously tried to train for a
marathon half marathon and I quit on the
first long run and I was like this is
terrible this is like torture why would
anyone do this but I can say I'm very
proud of myself you guys that not just
because of a New Year's resolution but
back in August I started working out
again and I was like okay I just I'm
done having babies I have three little
kids and I'm like I just want to feel
strong and feel good so I'm going to
start working out and if you've ever not
worked out and then worked out and you
wake up the next day oh my
gosh I woke up I got out of bed I was
like I can't I can't move like I I
literally can't move I mean you try to
get dressed in every part of you hurts
every part of you hurts this is probably
TMI but it's just the truth I remember
trying to go to the bathroom that
morning and I was like I I can barely
even sit down it's terrible it's
terrible but what I learned is when you
do that and your sore it's actually your
muscles tearing which is kind of
disgusting but that's what it is and so
that's why you want to eat and drink
protein and put good things in your body
because then your muscles grow and they
build and you continue on and you become
strong and that's what happens so in the
same way building new habits you guys
you're going to feel a little bit
hopefully not the physical pain but
you're going to feel a level of pain
because it's going to be different and
it's going to kind of hurt but here's
the deal when you do this over and over
again you start a new habit it becomes a
new part of who you are uh a lot of you
have probably read the book Atomic
Habits by James CLE and I love this
quote because it's a different mindset
when you look at this he says the
ultimate form of intrinsic motivation is
when a habit becomes a part of your
identity it's one thing to say I'm the
type of person who wants this it's a
very different thing to say I'm the type
of person who is this so when you look
at your money you guys take on a new
identity okay say man what are ways for
me to break this cycle if I'm in a
paycheck to paycheck cycle what can I do
well a very obvious one and one that
we're here at Ramsey that we always
teach is get out of debt right when you
don't have debt payments if your car
loan wasn't leaving and credit card
bills weren't leaving and your student
loan payment wasn't leaving how much
money would you have it's incredible but
you have to say to yourself I'm a person
that doesn't take on debt anymore that's
who I am you take on a new identity even
giving instead of saying yeah I want to
give some money no no no you are a
person who gives you take on that
identity saving and investing is the
same thing I am a person who delays
gratification and plans for the future
that is who I am contentment I am
somebody that does not have to keep up
with everybody else around me I am
running my own race you know even
budgeting I am someone who budgets that
is who I am and so these habits really
start to form into your identity and who
you are you guys and it is so crucial
and one of those habits that is so key
to Breaking the cycle especially the
paycheck to paycheck cycle it is
budgeting but we're not going to just
talk about it we're actually going to
show you how so to help me with a live
demo I want to Welcome to the stage Jay
Jade warshaw my friend Ramsey
personality what's going on Rachel Jade
okay so we're talking about this idea of
breaking the cycle and we really want to
break the paycheck to paycheck cycle and
let's define that what does that even
mean that means you have no savings you
have no cushion in your checking account
you have no margin so if you miss a
paycheck literally don't have your next
paycheck you're in a position that
you're like I I can't even pay my bills
I can't do anything absolutely look at
the end of the day if all you're doing
is eating you pay your bills and you
have no money left to do the things that
honestly make you a financially
responsible adult right you can't save
money you're not investing money forget
saving for kids college right that is
the definition Rachel of paycheck to
paycheck that's right so we want you to
live on Purp Pur and again most people
are not living on a budget but we're
going to walk through this and if you
are somebody that maybe you have the
every dollar app and you're and you're
using the you know you're using our
stuff and you're doing fantastic that's
amazing but if you're not let me just
tell you when you build out your first
budget there's kind of two camps of
people that we find some people they do
it and then they realize okay wow well
if I just cut this one category we're
good okay okay and then there's another
group of people probably majority of
people that when you get to it you see
wow we we're in the red deeply in the
red and I don't know what to do so
that's why Jade and I are here because
we really want to walk through and show
you how you can do this so well that's
right so when we talk about budgeting uh
there are some blockers like I could
feel it through the camera that some
people have objections they're like Jade
a budget listen I've got too much to do
already my kids the math like I hate
doing math if you're talking about
writing down numbers others of you are
like listen if you knew my spouse you
would know there's no way they're
sticking to a budget or possibly you've
tried a budget before and it just didn't
work for you here's the thing you were
probably doing it wrong so we're going
to teach you the right way and the good
news is every dollar which is the best
budgeting app there is is going to make
it so super easy for you we're going to
overcome every single one of those
objections tonight and we're going to
show you how to build your every dollar
budget in five minutes Rachel yeah
that's right yeah I mean doing this
through every dollar you guys it is so
easy it does the math for you and it's
wonderful so what we want you to do is
to click the link in the description and
that is what where you're going to build
your first budget you guys you're going
to do it online and then later on
through that because we have deals we
have promotions through that website we
want you to go to that link first and
foremost then you'll build you'll build
your budget there and then you'll use
the every dollar app and Jay usually I
my phone on me but we're doing an event
I'm being professional I don't have my
phone but what's great about the app you
guys is your it's on your phone we're
all attached to our phones and so it
goes with you in life which is what we
want this is a thing that is going to be
part of your daily habits and so it's so
key to have it convenient where it is
which is what we love and so again build
your budget there at the link but what
we're going to show you is the mobile
version so you can kind of see what
you're going to be doing and our friend
Bobby Bobby Bobby he's somewhere out
there he's gonna help us fill in some
numbers so let's go straight to this
budget so here's an every dollar budget
now when you do this you guys you want a
zero based budget which means your
income minus your expenses equals zero
so as you see Bobby is first filling out
the income here and then all the way
down Jer all these expens every do will
line items in the budget for you so you
can say oh yeah that's great I didn't
think about this and it's really there
to help you but there's going to be some
line line items that are there that you
don't need so you can delete those and
there's some that you're going to add
you're probably going to add a lot
that's how we are we we add a lot of
line items in our budget which is so
helpful so again as we're going through
he's just filling out all of these
numbers and the truth is especially if
you have a spouse probably one of you is
going to take the lead on building the
budget for the first time and as the
months go on but the key is once you've
kind of got it started you need to get
with your spouse and sit together and
truly decide on those end amounts so
that it's not like I've done this budget
here follow it this is the money you get
you do not want that energy in the house
so make sure you're deciding on the
numbers together and Jade a great way to
find the numbers if you don't know is go
back to your checking account the last
month or two kind of just average out
hey here's what we're spending on food
here's what our electric bill is but
know that those numbers are you not
budgeting okay so they might be a little
inflated so remember you may be able to
shrink some of those down because with a
budget you're living on purpose so true
yeah and I always say a good budget if
you're doing it right it should be
detailed realistic and flexible so when
I talk about detailed that's literally
the line item so you're going to see
things on there that are preset you can
change you can add more things the more
that you add anything you can think of
that you might spend money on you need
to include it in the budget that's being
detailed realistic Rachel yesterday's
prices they're not today's prices we
feel it listen groceries are more
expensive gas is more expensive make
sure you're being realistic with these
dollar amounts if you're a family of
four you're probably going to need more
than $150 for groceries I know we find
people all the time that get really
excited about this you guys like oh yeah
we'll eat for $50 a month and we're like
no no no because then it's going to mess
up your budget and it's not going to
work because it's not realistic and you
feel like you failed so just be
realistic and you're going to learn it
takes most people you know several
several months to really get it locked
in and that's okay and then finally just
be flexible this is living and breathing
with you right it's going with your
lifestyle I am voted most likely to go
over the budget in our household and I
receive that but if I go over a little
bit in groceries maybe I can take a
little from takeout yeah you know to to
balance it out and so that's the idea
however never take from a category
that's really important like saving or
paying off debt in order to balance the
budget that's right and just as you guys
are watching this just don't get hung up
on these specific numbers we kind of
took an average income of an American in
these average numbers these are an
example right you're going to plug in
your numbers and the other great thing
is Jade you know with people you're the
adult like you're doing this you get to
decide your numbers your budget is there
to work for your life okay that's what's
really key here so as you can see we
ended here with debt and it's always a
little bit sad to see okay all these
payments coming out that if you were if
you didn't have those payments if you're
getting out of debt and once you are
debt free all of that will stay in your
checking account which is awesome but
here we are we're
$325 over budget so when you're over
budget there's really two ways that you
can look at this you can cut expenses
and you can up income so when you cut
expenses uh Bobby let's go up to maybe a
restaurants which kind of hurts but when
you're in debt you're going to be
cutting a bunch of stuff you guys hurt
Rachel it does hurt I love real it does
hurt but what's crazy too Jade is we do
these webinars we've done every dollar
webinars with maybe some of you have
been with us with thousands of you and
there was someone recently that said
that they cut all their subscriptions
and they saved
$500 a month that's crazy subscriptions
it's unbelievable and then we talk to
people that get side hustles Jade and
they I mean they're making
$1,100 I mean it's wild what people are
making so even up at the income you can
be able to see okay where we can maybe
add some money absolutely you know some
of you you're looking at this and you're
like listen I have already gone down to
a barebones bud budget there's nothing
else that I can cut out if that's you
you probably need to look at bringing in
more income and that might look like a
side hustle or raising your income in
another way but most of us if we went
out and drove Uber did instacart you
could probably bring in at the bare
minimum an extra $500 a month so Bobby
let's add $500 a month there and just
see how it changes the number up top so
he adds the $500 and it's loading oh
there we go we have extra money to to
spend on $175 right what choose yeah
which is amazing now with every dollar
premium which again we're doing a great
deal you guys tonight here on the every
doll app for every dollar premium click
the link and make sure that you build
out that first budget you sign up
through that link build up that first
Budget on desktop then you can download
this app and use it dayto day but what
you're going to see are features that
are amazing we've heard you we know what
you want and Jade one of the best
features I think come on oh it's
paycheck planning you guys you've been
asking we hear you we got you I love
paycheck planning here's why CU I'm sure
I'm not the only person in this boat how
many of you have done a budget and
you're like yes I am adulting and you've
planned for everything you're like
Grandma's birthday I thought of
everything and then when the time comes
to like buy Grandma's gift there's no
money in the account it's so frustrating
or worse yet you overdraw the account
you're like what is happening I've been
budgeting somebody help me the problem
is you're not planning when to spend
your money okay a good budget tells your
money where to go but an even better
budget tells your money when to go and
that's what we're doing here with
Paycheck planning so Bobby let's take a
look at what paycheck planning looks
like because this is on honestly my
favorite feature of every dollar premium
so with Paycheck planning essentially
what you're doing is you're going in and
you're able to plan out each day that
you're going to spend your money so this
person happens to get paid on January
5th all right so we need to decide what
we can spend money on between this
paycheck and the next paycheck right so
she's got gas groceries electricity
miscellaneous everything's looking good
until we get down here to Mortgage in
rent oh my gosh she's going over there's
not enough money there won't be enough
money to cover it so what we can do here
is go okay how can we rearrange this
most of us have kind of Chunk items on
our budget things like groceries right
she's got $500 for groceries she's not
going to spend that all in one shot so
what I would do is I'd go in here click
it and let's spread it out and make it
more realistic your most people go
shopping once a week so let's put it on
Fridays $125 each week perfect spreads
it out spreads it out now it's not such
a weight on her paycheck and we look
down here and it's already looking
better now she's only got well did we
clear it up oh she's only got one thing
that's in the red so the next thing I'd
look at is okay let's look at this car
payment it comes out on the 9th maybe
your car payment when it comes out is
not convenient for you get on the phone
and call these people and say listen is
there any way I can move my car payment
let's move it to the 23rd my guess is
they're going to say yes because at the
end of the day they just want your money
they don't care when they get it they
just a lot of people will be flexible
with these payments so ask yeah and so
now we've moved that in look it's going
to change in a minute there's going to
be this is going to change from high
risk to low risk but if you scroll down
you'll see that she's no longer at the
risk of overspending and so that's how
paycheck planning works it's kind of
like a fun puzzle that you get to decide
how you spend your money yep it's
awesome and another great feature that
we have too you guys it takes 90 seconds
but it's to track your transactions so
what you're going to do is you're going
to on your phone you're going to touch
that you're GNA click that transaction
button and then you're going to go
through and and every dollar premium is
attached to your bank account so all of
your transactions drop into the every
dollar app which is amazing and so
you'll see bies which Little Piece of
Heaven on Earth we love I'm a WWA girl
all right oh Jane you got to go to bies
okay so bies will'll put in
transportation there in gas uh yeah you
have Publix we'll drop that in groceries
down below a little bit and then what
was next oh Nail Spa always if you're
not come on plan for the Y forget that
in you know the Cosmetics area
uh that I think we do have oh no there
may be a connection issue it said and
then last but not least okay so you're
going to have things like Amazon that
drop in so this is where you have to be
a little bit more detailed because
what's hard with Amazon I don't know if
this how you are Jade yes but we'll get
an Amazon transaction but it's I bought
a book and hangers and I don't know fill
in the blank and so it all is in all
these different categories that's right
so you can actually split the
transaction so important because you
want your grocery budget to be for
grocery and you want your clothing for
clothing so let's go through here we
could split it let's put some of it on
groceries put some of it on clothing
let's see and you can it's easy to
search up top so if you're looking for
that category you can select it and put
whatever amount goes in that category
and then you can come down and say okay
also I had clothing as part of that
purchase and that way you're really
being accurate about how you're tracking
your transactions because Rachel if
you're like me I like to know like I
want to know what I'm spending my money
on and this is going to give you an
accurate picture of how you're spending
your money yeah and let me just speak a
little bit to like the Nerds out there
or maybe this is for the free Spirits
you don't have to do like every little
scent okay so if it's like the hangers
were1 12 like wait what wait a minute ra
I'm just kidding I know I know so just
make it easy on yourself you can make it
quick just it's the idea that again you
are following your life and you're
spending and your budget is right there
with you to give you permission so again
building out that budget you guys click
that link build your first budget
through that link because tonight we
have so many great deals for you we want
you to get plugged into this stuff you
guys and then later on you'll download
the app and you'll get all of this there
on your phone now the last thing that I
think is probably one of the best
features is that month to month every
dollar will duplicate your budget so
here in January you go in up there and
you can click to
February and then as you click to
February it's going to just duplicate
all of your numbers now you still have
to be proactive go in there because
there'll be line items from January that
you don't need in February there'll be
new line items in February where you'll
want to add so again you're still being
proactive in your budget but you don't
have to start from scratch which is so
great Jade because every month is
different and that's why I love every
dollar no that's right so you guys to
recap remember you can make your first
budget in five minutes click that link
in the description to build that first
budget plan your paychecks no matter
when you're paid what you're being paid
plan them out and also make sure to
track your transactions because that is
so key and Jade that's what keeps it an
every dollar budget which we love okay
so we're g to pinch it back over to Dave
to share an exciting announcement about
a giveaway ah time to give away our
first $11,000 as a reminder we're giving
away
$110,000 tonight and Eric a from North
Dakota is our first winner Eric our team
will be in touch with you and we'll get
your $1,000 out we're going to give away
another $99,000 over the next few
minutes so be watching look for your
name in the chat that's where we'll be
doing it and uh earlier I said that most
of you watching said you're not
consistently following a budget that you
couldn't miss a paycheck you're right on
the edge you're in this crisis mode and
also most of you said that your primary
emotions when it comes to money are fear
shame and guilt and finally 80% of
people in America have said they've been
in this financial situation for most of
our adult life guys this is the moment
to decide are you going to break the
cycle you've been trapped most of your
ad life are you going to break this
we've all got enough excuses not enough
time not enough money it's my parents
fault it's my spouse's fault it's the
president's fault it's not at some point
it's my fault now these things may not
be your fault but they are your
responsibility and it comes down to a
choice you have the right and the
obligation to do something different if
you choose to stay stay right where you
are what is this cycle costing you a
life of mediocrity Stress and Anxiety
instead you could choose peace Financial
Peace two words that don't go together
like Airline service you can have peace
at life peace at work peace in your
relationships and these things all do
run together now I value peace because
like some of our other MSY personalities
I've lived the opposite I've lived in
fear even Terror when I was 28 years old
I was at the bottom of a deep valley I
had started with nothing and I built a
$4 million portfolio of real estate with
a million dollar net worth and making
$250,000 a year in
1982 long time ago it was a lot of money
back then but I blew it I borrowed too
much money I got too far in debt and I
fell way over the edge and the year
Rachel was born I had a brand new baby a
toddler and a marriage Hanging On by a
thread and we filed
bankruptcy it was
awful I remember standing in the shower
with as hot as I could stand it in my
face and I'd stand there and just cry
because I was so freaking scared and I
didn't know what to do so I had to do
something different you know the old
saying if you keep doing what you've
been doing you're going to keep getting
what you've been getting and you know
the other old saying continuing to do
the same thing over and over again and
expecting a different result is the
definition of insanity we've heard these
things but when you're in a situation
like that you got to change so I decided
we're going to start doing something
different and you can do something
different same is true for
you take what you've learned tonight use
the tools we're going to show you and
start to win tonight your night start
right now every dollar premium that Jade
and Rachel just talked about where it
connects to your bank tracks checks your
transactions every day it's the
financial equ equivalent of weighing
yourself every morning after you're
working out doing your run it use that
play paycheck planning that comes with
the every dollar premium to get your
confidence to spend get the stuff in the
right part of the month where the thing
actually freaking Works get in one of
our free one-on-one coaching sessions
and daily group coaching from our team
and we put together a 90-day plan with
every dollar and it's going to guide you
through every next right step with your
money we're going to hold your hand and
show you how to do this every dollar
premium is normally $79.99 a year but
tonight it's only $64.99 that's less
than $6 a month and we all know that's
less than one cup of Starbucks right so
to get this deal click the link in the
description or go to everydollar.com
start our second offer is Ramsey plus
it's the whole Angela it's the second
option tonight allinone and it gives you
all the stuff I just talked about with
every dollar premium every dollar
premium is there plus a ton more it
includes Financial Peace University
which is our nine lesson in class that
10 million people in America have been
through to learn how to get out of debt
get on a budget agree on spending with
their spouse change their generosity and
become baby steps millionaires there's
courses in there in addition to
Financial Peace University on anxiety
with Dr John deloney we've got parenting
stuff in there career stuff from Ramsey
personality Ken Coleman increasing your
income and all of the audio books from
all of our Ramsey personalities best
sellers are in there included for free
and you know if you start listening to
those audio books in your car on your
way to work your car turns into
automobile University you can get the
equivalent of a University degree just
listening to this kind of stuff in your
car instead of listening to the junk
we've also got Ramsey smart tax in there
which is our tax software it's included
free you can file your taxes free and
Ramsey plus is normally $129 for all of
that tonight $99 which of course is less
than $8 a month to get that same deal go
to the same Link in in the description
right now or go to everydollar.com
slstart either one of them will cause
you to move forward whether you just get
the basic premium or whether you do the
whole enchilada with Ramsey plus it's a
no-brainer guys now it's time to quit
saying one day start saying day one get
on the same page with your spouse get
control of your money be intentional
start to think out 90 days what's it
going to be like when you get to spring
break this year and you don't have any
payments or you get to Spring Break and
you're in control for the first time
ever this is crazy we're going to be
walking with you and there's a, 1100
folks on the Ramsey team at Ram in right
here in Nashville and we're all thinking
about you we spend millions of dollars
on this every dollar app constantly
upgrading it iterating it making it
better same with Financial Peace
University we're there for you we exist
to help you change your whole future to
create transformation so you can create
your account right now by clicking the
link in the description or visiting
everydollar.com
start now we got a plan we've been
talking about with Dr John delone we
hear Rachel you've gotten of course
George camel and I really want you to
hear from one of my favorite speakers on
the planet our own Jade warshaw she's
going to help you talk about someday in
a whole different way so Jade it's all
yours wow Dave thank you so much hey I'm
glad you guys are here tonight on this
live stream you know we've all seen
those great action movies right that
have those amazing car chase scenes I'm
thinking about Keanu Reeves before the
Matrix George all right speed okay I'm
thinking about Uma Thurman and Kill Bill
or maybe Liam niss yes a classic come on
the taken movies that is Liam niss in
his prime but the hero is always in a
getaway car right he's like speeding to
get away from these bad guys and if it's
a really good movie there's the not only
himself to save but he's got like women
and children in the car that he needs to
save as well and inevitably what does
the hero face there's always a barrier
right there's always another car or
something to jump over uh separating the
hero from where he needs to go my
favorite barrier the chain link fence
man the chain link fence is always in
the way it's always closed tight with
one of those padlocks on it and of
course it's got the barbed wire on the
top of the fence and somehow it's on a
bridge too a bridge with water on every
side and a very steep fall if the hero
were to go off the bridge and the hero
believes if he can just bust through
that fence there's freedom on the other
side right if you can just get past
those bad guys chasing him it'll no
longer be a threat so with sweat pouring
down his face and his eyes narrowed he's
focused he pushes the pedal to the midle
the car Rams through the fence and of
course that sets off a series of like
random explosions in the back background
ensuring that our bad guy is no longer a
problem and the hero busts through the
fence the gates burst wide open and he
drives off into the sunset wow what a
great scene that's a great movie man we
love movies like that don't we we love
when the hero is both Brave and
courageous we love to see the hero win
but what if this scene were different
let's take a moment and Rewind back
let's think for a moment what what if
the hero approached the fence with his
Nemesis gaining on him but instead of
speeding the car up he actually began to
slow the car down as a matter of fact he
comes to a complete stop when he gets to
the fence and then our hero gets out of
the car and he kind of begins cautiously
you know walking around seeing if
there's a way to get around the fence he
tries the padlock no that won't work and
when he realizes there's no way to get
around the fence or through the fence he
gets back back into the car and instead
of gunning the engine forward he puts
the car in Reverse he doesn't believe
that he has the ability to go through
the fence or around the fence and so he
puts the car in reverse and drives back
towards the very mess and the Very chaos
that he was trying to escape man this
movie sucks I don't know about you but I
want my money back okay what happened to
our hero and yet this is what so many of
us do when it comes to our money our
money Journey it's like we're all hype
and no fight right we come to the
beginning of the year and we're like all
right I'm ready this is my year this is
the year I'm getting out of debt I'm
getting on a budget I'm getting
everything on track and we feel super
optimistic until the moment that we Face
a barrier right we come against that
fence and the moment we hit it we want
to turn and go back the other way
because we don't believe that we
actually have what it takes to bust
through that barrier now Rachel and I we
just laid the plan out for you we gave
you the blueprint but if there's
anything I've learned it's this if
behavior is your getaway car belief is
what's in the driver's seat okay your
belief is what drives your behavior
depending on what you believe you'll
either Ram through that fence right or
you'll put the car in reverse and go
back the other way listen this plan the
plan we laid out for you that's not your
driver's seat Dave Ramsey he's not in
your driver seat I'm certainly not in
your driver's seat your belief is the
only thing in your driver's seat and I
can tell you you're always going to
encounter barriers okay on this
financial Journey you're going to hit
mental blocks okay these obstacles they
are guaranteed but you won't make
progress you won't Ram that fence if you
don't actually believe that it's
possible for someone like you okay and I
know some of you are like Okay Jade I'm
getting it that's me like I'm the one
who keeps getting caught up in the same
cycle of fear and guilt and shame and
I'll be honest yeah Jade it has caused
me to retreat but what am I supposed to
do about that can you help me how can I
change that well I've got two thoughts
for you and this is what's worked for me
okay number one you've got to challenge
those beliefs okay 2 Corinthians 10:5
tells us we have to take every thought
captive and make it obedient to Christ
in other words we've got to take our
thoughts and make them obedient to
what's true okay maybe you're like Jade
I don't read the Bible I'm not a
Christian person that's okay I'm happy
you're here but let's look at what Dr
John delone says he says we have to
demand evidence of our thoughts so much
of what we believe is simply not true
and so this is the time that we've got
to get serious about calling out those
thoughts case some point I'll be the
first example when when I was a kid uh a
phrase that I heard over and over
growing up was this we ain't got no
money we ain't got no money for this we
ain't got no money for that was it true
probably not but it didn't matter
because I believed it and as an adult I
started kind of taking that on as my
status in life I ain't got no run I
ain't got no money so that's the reason
that I've got to borrow money uh I ain't
got no money so that's the reason that
there's limitations on my income it just
makes sense and I ain't got no money so
a budget prob wouldn't help me maybe
you've got that same I ain't got no
money thought of your own maybe it's
somebody like me just can't save money
or a budget could never help somebody in
my situation or whatever your exception
to the rule may be listen this is the
time to get your mind right man you got
to start challenging those thoughts all
right Jade I hear you guys you're like
all right Jade I'm rocking with you like
I can see I definitely have some money
thoughts that could be better I
definitely have some of those screwed up
thoughts as it relates to money what can
I do about it what do I do next all
right here's the next thing to do you
got to flood your mind with truth all
right Romans 122 tells us be transformed
by the renewing of your mind simply put
you got to get new thoughts into your
mind okay and at the end of the day
think about that old adage right
whatever you feed grows and whatever you
starve dies so it's time to start
staring starving those negative untrue
beliefs about money that haven't been
serving you anyway and start feeding
yourself truth and I can tell you this
when you get involved with ramsy
Solutions man you're really just getting
involved with a community of Truth
tellers we're going to tell you the
truth all right through FPU through
ramsy plus certainly through every
dollar most definitely through the
Ramsay show if you're not listening to
that you need to be but this is you
flooding your mind with truth now when
my husband Sam and I were getting out of
our debt we paid off
$460,000 of debt guys that half a
million almost of debt and I can tell
you this I knew it was a financial
Journey but I also knew it was a mindset
and a belief journey I had to get my
mind right so we were listening to the
Ramsey show every day okay I'm opening
up that every dollar app every single
day and I was engaged with other things
like Financial Peace University even to
the point that I even taught Financial
Peace University with my husband and by
doing that that's a merging oursel in
Daily truth to the point where those
weak lies that we used to believe about
money man they started to just sound
ridiculous they started to fall by the
wayside and we started to realize how
much power we actually had I was able to
change my mind I was able to change my
beliefs and you can too listen I want
you to look right here I want you to
know that you're more powerful than you
could ever imagine okay you can
accomplish more than you ever thought
possible and this year it's hard pass on
anything that tells you otherwise listen
2024 this is your year you're speeding
towards off fence right now use this
momentum use this feeling to bust
through it now are you going to be that
person who just lets that same old cycle
of fear and guilt and shame turn you
around or are you going to be the hero
who busts through the barrier and breaks
the
cycle be the hero speaking of Heroes I'd
love to bring back to the stage Dave
Ramsey thanks Jade you're incredible wow
if you aren't fired up after that
something's wrong with you hard to hard
to light wet wood wow as we said before
personal finance is 80% Behavior it's
20% head knowledge if I can get the guy
in my mirror to behave he can be skinny
and Rich and the way you change behavior
is you change your beliefs and the way
you change your beliefs as you get new
information a new way of looking at
things you can do that through several
lenses and we've tried to help you with
all of those lenses tonight we can go
through the intellectual lens the
academic lens and so we get two phds up
here with Dr John deloney looking at
this through all the nerd stuff and
trying to get you that way hey we can
recognize our outside foes and our enemy
who's the villain it's not you but it is
your responsibility and George helped
you with that you can look at it through
the lens of community people around you
because you become who you hang around
with that's for sure and you can look at
it through the lens like Jade helped us
with of the spiritual and what God's got
to say about this the more lenses that
you look at your situation through and
adjust your behaviors the more likely
you are to control of this area of your
life
now we're offering this tool tonight as
we said every dollar buy tonight the
premium access for one year with
one-on-one coaching group coaching
90-day plan we're going to walk with
you you can check it all out and be sure
and click the link I'm often asked when
I'm being interviewed Dave what's the
number one mistake people make with
their
money probably heard that a bazillion
times in the last 30 years as if there's
like credit card or crypto or there's
one stupid thing that's more stupid than
the other stupid things and it's not the
number one mistake people make with
their money is they don't pay attention
they're not
intentional no one becomes successful at
anything no one wins at anything unless
it's a series of intentional acts no one
accidentally has a great marriage no one
accidentally has a great career no one
accidentally wins the World Series
no one accidentally wins it's a series
of
intentional acts now why would you take
these intentional acts that are painful
usually because there's a price to be
paid to win we know that why would we do
that if we didn't think they were going
to work I mean it'd be a psychological
disorder if you were just doing it just
for the pain right no we do it because
we believe they're going to work when
you believe they're going to work that's
called
hope and hope when it's not there there
man it lets the air out of everything
Proverbs says hope deferred makes the
heart
sick hopelessness makes the heart sick
and the proverb continues and says but
when desire comes it is the Tree of Life
the great motivator Les Brown has always
said people change their lives when they
finally get sick and tired of being sick
and tired and they have that moment
where they say that's it I've had
it when you've had an I had it moment
you don't care what other people
think and you're going to change
something I hope tonight we can lead you
to your I've had it moment which is
where hope is born because now things
change when hope is born because hope
hope is what we do at Ramsay we know a
lot about it it's very real we see it
light up in people's eyes when they
start to believe and right after that's
when they change their behaviors and
right after that is when we see them
start to win thanks for joining us
tonight we love you and we're cheering
you on 2024 is going to be awesome
[Music]
baby